[Music]
and unusual funeral news Oh submitted by
wife is so awesome thank you buddy
massaging a man slept next to his dead
wife's body for six days and recommends
the experience that is gross because
after you die your [ __ ] expels out your
blood crack and you pee and poo
everything out but I don't even mind if
geo exposed stuff out of her butt crack
which is alive right next to you in bed
but there's also going to be like a
rotting smellable in addition to the
poop and the pee it's not actually like
this idea I don't even know what he
likes about it
but from what I take from it is so
imagine you guys your loved one is
terrific another yeah you love them for
the bad breath I buggers the [ __ ] smell
like you've been through all that with
them you spend like 40 50 years 60 years
with them and and now they're passed
away instead of removing yourself and
all you have are these like memories and
then you start morning kind of like
alone you get to gradually see them kind
of like disintegrate and fall apart and
there's this I feel like there's a
sealing process where like maybe there
are some words that you were never able
to say and you could still continuously
like mourn and kind of like he'll do all
that I think I could do that without
looking at the dead body go I think it's
more real I don't know think about like
if you lose I know you hate thinking
about this but if you lose your mom
suddenly you know you wouldn't want to
just be by your side because that is
something that's a paper but you'd like
in the animals to they don't stick
around the dead body either what also
trying to survive though yeah but that's
not natural like even in like animal
kingdom it's not natural though more in
the body but they don't stick around and
watch decay they have to continue
they'll still more do animals are still
separate actually they do they do stick
around if you've had dogs that grew up
together they get really really sad and
they'll just kick it with them to take
care of them I've even seen it in rat
[ __ ] yeah that's like the soldiers with
jenolan or the casket their dog is
taught to feel older they don't want to
leave that casket when one of art one of
my rats I'd given one was just like over
it like just trying to take care of it
because I don't I don't think looking at
a dead body it helps me mourn the loss
you know I mean I think it's even more
visceral than looking at memories
because you're just watching a decay in
front and that's more of it as [ __ ] for
me you know I mean that's why even with
like I don't like open casket either you
know that's like not my thing
but uh other people seem to enjoy it
yeah just because it's not the same
person it's like the the life is gone so
like when the person dies that person is
not that person I agree with you 100%
kazaaam I did have someone really close
to me passed away and it was open casket
and it was very painful but then at that
point I was like well they're gone like
that it doesn't even feel like this yeah
like it's not them anymore but then I
try to imagine myself in the position of
like growing old with with Bart right
like we already have like a 10 year of
knowing or 11 years like knowing one
another and now like raising a kid
together having a life together if we
pass when we're like in our late sixties
or something that's like 30 plus years
right that we've been together I can see
why people is just like dennis is like
your best friend this is your other half
yes I see that too but I think you could
feel that same way with your parents oh
man Iike they better not even longer
than your significant other they have
that they haven't been as invested at
least for me I feel like I they're not
as invested as like they don't know me
the same way that he you know you know
it's completely different like yeah I
love them I respect them but I don't
know everything about them they don't
know everything about me but then with
him it's like it's different I think my
mom knows me better than I know myself
oh yeah I said to my dad because I have
a really close relationship with them so
like if I if you know my malt a so I'll
be devastated for years on an even my
grandma passing right now if I think
about it now it makes me super who do
you think would know your jackoff
pattern your mom or my mom you know
jejak our mom knows everything about me
did we talk four or five times a week
you tell you when you jerk off well
that's our coffee but I put that
closeness you know what I mean like like
that's how I thing you'd probably share
with I don't think that no matter what
Muriel will ever be will ever get to
know certain things about me that my mom
knows that she doesn't do what my mom
has seen me from birth till now so there
are specific things that she has seen
about me and knows about me like
behavior wise that she could already
what I'm going to do and that's how
close that is I'm not sure how it is
with you guys and your parents but
that's how it is to be a mom
I know Jill knows me that my mom knows
me so it's a little different you know I
mean so like my mom like even like if
she sees me she knows exactly what's
wrong with me you know Muriel can't even
do that and so I think like with with
the type of relationship I had with my
mom I'm pretty sure like the closer
nighttime with my with Muriel will be
just as close but it would be in a
different type of place right so I could
draw from that I could draw from the
other thing where I just feel like even
if I'm on task yeah I probably have an
open casket but I would have want them
to be next to me as I'm watching them
die that's something I don't need I also
it's also probably a religious thing for
me to like mmm this is just a one one
stop thing for now and for the next one
so for me I'm not attached at his body
here that's right now because it's for
me if that was the case I think I will
be like very scared you know No so this
story is about Wendy and Russell Wendy
had passed away after a long ten year
plus battle with cervical cancer and her
husband Russell posted a really really
long really beautiful Facebook post once
she passed explaining like their love
together like her whole journey with its
cancer like what they decided to do once
they found out that she was diagnosed
with cancer back in 2006 and like you
just talked about how immediately Wendy
wanted to go like the full natural route
like she did not want any Western
medicine and she changed her diet
retained her lifestyle like all of them
and he really believed that it prolonged
her life a lot and so it got to the
point where she was feeling well enough
to where they wanted to travel all
across Europe because they're from the
UK they got like a caravan of a they
travel for three years they went to 15
countries and they just were living life
to the fullest
reading his posts and I know I'm
emotional but I was like I had like
friggin water in my eyes I'm just like
oh my god is is so beautiful and so
sweet because like everything like you
described like their love is just really
beautiful and so he was just saying like
you know he kept asking her like is
there anything else you would want to do
right now as like they were exploring or
like having adventures together as I
know this is exactly where I want to be
perfectly happy doing what we're doing
right now
three years ago she got the cancer back
again because she was in remission and
then they gave her six months to live a
little high
that was three years ago so then that's
when death was becoming more real and
they're very spiritual people I think
they practice like Judaism as well so
just really spiritual people so they
were just saying like you know what like
we've come to terms of death and like
they've started planning out how they
would handle everything when she passes
and so what she wanted and what he
wanted as well as like once she passed
he didn't want her to just be wrapped up
in a black bag and just stuck in a
freezer at the morgue all alone because
and because of their so spiritual
they're saying like when a person dies
their spirit if they're just taken away
immediately into a strange place that
they don't know like they're going to be
confused entering the spirit world and
like you might not know where I go and I
don't have GPS miss Perriman
yeah they don't so then that's how like
the libraries end up staying on earth is
what they're explaining and so he's
saying like you guys just made a lot of
sense to me to want to keep her body
with me and like to be able to mourn
with her and like have like that entire
process and he said like for six days he
kept her and what they like to call a
cocoon cuz she like she doesn't like the
word coffin
so her cocoon was like right next to
their bed and so I keep saying I use
really comforting to be able to sleep
and know that she's in the same room
with me so it was it was it's more or
less not dead body it's a spiritual
experience for me
it is yeah I mean he's like anyways
really doing is all the shitty didn't
want to say yeah it's like that's right
[ __ ] twenty feet I'm a lead bash it up
I'm a watch TV take my [ __ ] beer in
yo [ __ ] face what you gonna do what
are you gonna do
Velvets are doing you're not I'm not
saying if please just you guys can you
guys take care of roasting my
everything's ruined
I don't know Tiffany can you please like
I might leave the comp index there's
like hey bro do what you want especially
because toenails my first paid speech in
the bit and what else it's not like you
like cuddling a dead body right because
that's like when you first said the
article that's that's what I was
thinking you know I think the same thing
too yeah I wasn't like that and I
thought it was more like you wanted the
physical body it seems like a more
spiritual thing there's like a reason
and a purpose but now and now for me
because I owe it makes sense then no
after the reading this entire experience
like I'm like I told Katie right after
he was upstairs he came downstairs after
I read this and I was looking like
what's wrong and I'm like good as a
resident is no beautiful I'm like when I
die I want you to keep my body okay
she's like what you always say you're
gonna die person like I don't know I
feel like I am he's older one I know but
I I keep telling him oh married women
live shorter yeah
single women live woman they want to
stress themselves out like a
[ __ ] takes years off your life
span everyday winds like a thousand
years it was for women what we very hate
what that's why you guys are still alive
now you're gonna specifically other guys
a younger wonder single know like even
married no guys as guys are married they
live longer and then if guys are seeing
where they live shorter oh maybe it's
cuz I favor both no it's the opposite so
single women live longer married women
lives oh you know what it is maybe it's
because you guys are always picking up a
presence on your life yeah we keep you
alive longer killer some floss stupid
[ __ ] yeah because when I see like
pictures of Tyson sometimes I still have
messages I want to tell them so I'm
always talking to the pictures in the
house all we have a blanket with all the
Tyson on that when I see him hey lady
they still want to talk to him so I can
bat feeling of wanting to like still
connect somehow I mean even though
knowing that he's dead I still want to
connect to them I can see that happening
with someone that I love yeah you
haven't let that go by the way cuz
meatloaf looks exactly
exactly I know there I know they're
really separate though hi I never
confuse the names and I was harsh I do
and I always talk [ __ ] sorry where my
[ __ ] Tyler Clementi looks last time
what wouldn't be obvious Barney I was
like Tyson oh [ __ ] I heard all the time
I'm like piss man like relay whatever
happened down like yeah I'll contestant
I mean damn it meat loaf nah I didn't
realize I'll call you - until I feel
like cases on your leg - I felt like oh
what the [ __ ] I think just reminds me
exactly of that dog yeah so like after
he on Tyson passed away you ER you got
him community right yeah so like the
other day I saw this video where like
this guy's offering the service square
he'll take your animal body and kind of
like stuff it that's what my dad wanted
would you think that or no that's that's
too much for me I think like there's a
mourning period and then I think there's
a time to move on that's it for me like
if I had Tyson like dead next to me for
a week I think that'd be cool mmm but
then sup like put them into like a
stuffed body and then how to stay there
for like the rest of my life that's kind
of too much for me if you can like hug
him when you want like everything
rock-hard well now we have no fellowship
I have a beta fish-- tooth and that's
full
you better get a week than they're going
year-and-a-half now who's gonna live
that dude what is their lifespan like
two three years so it's almost time I
could tell this colors going out now
ah I'm gonna how sad I don't even know
why I'm looking at him on my dude your
[ __ ] fish [ __ ] out of him
but you know why is because every
morning I wake up I get out of bed
I look at him I go good morning Frankie
and I give him two pellets and I go rank
us all right yeah Frank Ocean I call
them Frankie now look I'm like so you're
gonna die and I get a little sad but I
should know that there's life span is
super short anyway so sighs why am i
investing my emotions it is a little
[ __ ] but you still raised it those like
do we have a connection to it yeah yeah
and then finally after a while when
shoot when they see you they understand
that you're gonna give them food so they
float right up to the top like this good
morning I'm like hey Frankie BAM Frankie
you're crazy what you do how often does
he um flare
[Music]
not off these oldest [ __ ] now he used to
buy gold now like Oh [ __ ] I want to
going on Vicky a news fans hope you guys
like that episode remember to follow our
personal social media and of course if
you want to watch more videos might you
know where to go your [ __ ] right
up there
[Music]